welcome to saz talks money on
valuetainment i'm your host adam sosnick
and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode we're
going to be breaking down
joe biden's economic plan and what it
means for you
and your finances let's talk money all
we talk is money
all right so off top let me start off by
saying that we're gonna go
under the assumption that joe biden will
be the next president of the united
states if for some reason
trump pulls a rabbit out of the hat and
becomes president then completely
disregard this entire episode so we're
gonna be making a few
assumptions during this episode and
something that you guys should know at
home
i don't care if you're on the left i
don't care if you're on the right
republican if you voted for trump he
voted for biden
this is not a political segment
whatsoever it is
all about your money something that you
should be aware of as this new
presidency takes
shape how this will affect your finances
so let's understand where a joe biden
presidency
will mean for the economy another round
of stimulus and your
finances so here's a quote that joe
biden said
as soon as he was elected into office he
says joe biden says
we are facing a health crisis an
economic crisis
a racial justice crisis and climate
crisis
we need to come together to solve these
as american so there you have it he
painted a picture
of the crisis that americans are
currently
facing all right what else are we facing
we're facing high unemployment
we're facing low inflation and we're
facing zero interest rates right now in
the economy
top that all off with a spike in covet
cases and literally
winter is now coming like it's freaking
game of thrones because we are in mid
november and the weather ain't getting
any
warmer so we'll see what happens with
kova that of course is the big
question on everyone's mind let's talk
about the political challenges
that joe biden is likely to be facing
again
in this episode we're making a few
assumptions
assumption number one is that joe biden
is actually the president okay we can
assume that
number two let's talk about the
assumption that we will more than likely
have a divided congress what does that
mean
it means that the gop the republican
party is more than likely
going to have a slim majority in the
senate
all eyes are on georgia georgia is on
all our minds like ray charles once said
and here's why because they're going to
have a couple senate
runoffs in early january assuming those
play out the way they're they're looking
to play out even if one or possibly two
seats go to the gop republicans will
more than likely
hold the senate now on the other hand
democrats have a slim
majority in the house we know we saw
that during the midterm elections
of 2018 they had a big win for the house
they lost a few seats during the 2020
election
but they still hold the house the gop
likely to hold the senate
and obviously joe biden a democrat looks
to be
the president united states what does
that all mean for wall street well wall
street not sure if you know this or not
wall street actually likes gridlock they
like the fact that we have a democratic
president
that we have a democratic house but we
also have a potential
gop senate because it keeps things in
check they keep they like
gridlock we saw under trump with a
republican president and a republican
senate and a democratic
house that the market did just fine so
the stock market actually likes
gridlock now where do we stand as far as
gdp gross domestic product as far as
right now well in q2 we got absolutely
crushed that
gdp plummeted 31 but in q3 we
bounced back 33 percent now we are in q4
and we're wondering what the hell is
going on
now that we have a new president coming
into the white house
so what i've done behind you is i've
broken down the 10 things
that you need to be paying attention to
regarding a biden
economic plan so let's jump into this
top 10
right now so topic number one is climate
change as you can see behind me climate
is number one and i didn't put that
number one because i feel that way i
actually put it in alphabetical order
just because we know people are gonna
say well why do you think that this is
more important than this and this and
this
it's all in alphabetical order as you
can see so climate change is number one
and joe biden has said
quote unquote climate change is the
number one issue
facing humanity how do you feel about
that is that something that you think is
the
number one issue that we are facing as
americans or as humans
walking around this globe right now is
climate change number one well according
to joe biden that is number one now he
put together a plan what's that plan
called it's called the clean
energy revolution now what's going to
happen in this revolution he basically
put together a 2
trillion dollar plan to make america
invest into clean
energy what else is joe biden going to
do he definitely says he's going to
re-enter
the paris climate accord trump made
breaking news as soon as he became
president
in 2016 and he completely exited
the paris climate accord how do you feel
about biden re-entering the climate
accord
please leave your comments below when it
comes to that he also says he's going to
spend 400 billion dollars
on renewable energy research and watch
out if you are in the oil
or gas sectors because that's something
that he's going to be cracking down on
when it comes to pollution
and certainly cars polluting the
environment that's joe biden's stance
on climate what else last but not least
what are his goals his goals are to
become
100 a clean energy economy by 2035
his second goal is to have zero net
emissions
by 2050. now what is some of the
pushback that joe biden is receiving
well on the left
on his own party on the left side of the
democratic party you got people like
bernie sanders
and aoc and elizabeth warren that are
upset that he didn't go bigger obviously
they're fans
of the green new deal the g n d
they wanted him to go bigger and spend
more on climate change
and then you got the republicans like
whoa buddy relax
they don't want to go too big on climate
change
so that's number one everything that you
need to understand when it comes
to joe biden's number one thing climate
moving right along let's talk about
number two
we'll move along to health care when it
comes to health care you
know joe biden has his homeboy barack
obama's back what does he want to do he
wants to protect
the aca aka obamacare and what does he
want to do he wants to provide
a medicare like public option if you
don't know about medicare it's usually
for people 65 and older but he wants to
spread it out
for everybody however he does not
believe in universal health care
we'll touch on that in a second what
else does he want to do he wants to
lower
the max out-of-pocket coverage from nine
point eight percent
down to eight point five percent aka you
won't have to spend as much
on your health care out of pocket he
wants to lower drug prices i think
that's something everyone's down for
and what he also wants to do is he wants
to end what is known as surprise
billing surprise mother sucker surprise
a bill you get from an
out of network provider wrapping this
part up let's talk about what's going on
with covet here are the things he wants
to do when it comes to cove but he wants
to provide free testing he wants to
distribute
ppe all across the country he wants mass
scale contact tracing and last but not
least he wants paid leave
for sick workers so if you're sick and
you have to miss work at least you'll
still be
making some income due to coven last but
not least which we touched on in the
beginning
he is not for universal health care aka
medicare for all that the
ultra left wing of the party is calling
for biden has said it
is too costly save that money let's move
on to number three
the number three thing is immigration
this was something that trump
harped on like crazy he wanted to build
a wall he didn't want illegal immigrants
coming to america
now joe biden has a complete different
take when it comes to immigration let's
break that down
he wants to have sweeping immigration
reform what does that mean exactly
basically he wants to introduce a
pathway to citizenship for dreamers or
daca recipients
and undocumented immigrants who what pay
their taxes cha-ching that's money
coming into united states
he also wants to invest four billion
dollars into
latin american country so they feel safe
enough not to have to leave their
homeland and come to united states so
that's what he wants to do for latin
america
last but not least he would reverse some
of trump's
executive actions i.e a travel ban on
certain
muslim countries he would actually
increase immigrants and refugees from
other countries
and last but not least he would increase
h-1b
visas which are basically visas for
high-skilled
foreign workers respect on that so
what's his plan what's his plan when it
comes to overall immigration well let me
tell you he number one wants to boost
the population
interesting boost the population he
wants to boost
the labor supply aka workers he wants to
increase
consumer spending spend that money and
he also wants to increase
productivity so that's joe biden's plan
when it comes
to immigration number four on this list
is income
inequality not sure you know this but
check any article out there
they're saying that income inequality is
the highest it's been
in 50 years obviously with covet going
on the rich are getting richer
the poor are struggling this is known as
the k-shaped economy
check it out for yourselves well joe
biden wants to devote a hundred
billion dollars in low-interest loans to
local
communities of color he also wants to
set up 50
billion dollars in startup capital for
entrepreneurs of color
he wants to invest 70 billion into hbcus
which are historically
black college and universities and he
also wants to establish a federal
commission on reparations very
interesting would love to know your
thoughts on that
i know that's a very controversial topic
now when it comes to college and student
loans let's address that before we move
on what does joe biden want to do but he
wants to introduce
four years of free college public
university
to families who are making under 125
000 a year that's not poor people 125
thousand dollars
for a family of four that's very middle
class interesting so he basically wants
to expand
college in america he will also provide
loan forgiveness if you are paying
responsibly
for 20 years responsibly drink
responsibly we know that people talk
about that they want you to
pay responsibly your student loans he
will also cut
your payments in half of your
discretionary income
from 10 to as low as 5 of what you
actually have to pay
back when it comes to your student loans
and last but not least he's willing to
forgive
ten thousand dollars in federal
student loans moving on to the next
topic number five is
infrastructure what does joe biden want
to do well joe biden has a plan
called the build back better build back
better is joe biden's plan his
proposal is 7 trillion
over the next 10 years of spending that
is more than likely to get
chop chop chopped up in half if it ever
gets to congress
what does joe biden want to do well he
wants to upgrade roads
bridges and highways and also he wants
to implement a high
speed rail system here in america and
he's relying
on a public and private partnership in
order to do that
one more topic that's important to bring
up when it comes to infrastructure
let's talk about housing joe biden wants
to invest 640 billion dollars into
affordable housing i'm cool with that he
also wants to end
redlining and discriminatory practices
when it comes to housing and what else
does he want to do he wants to provide
housing vouchers so families don't have
to pay more than 30 percent of their
income
in rent i talk about all this all the
time
you want to keep your rent below 30
percent of your income so i'm actually
cool with biden on that
so that's what he has to discuss when it
comes to infrastructure
let's move on to number six number six
on the list is labor
aka jobs so what does joe biden want to
do with that well just like trump has
slogans like america first america first
joe biden has a couple other slogans
that he would like to introduce that
hopefully catch on he's touting
made in all of america and
by american not sure if that's too
original but those are joe
biden's slogan and that's what he's
standing by he would like to spend
700 billion dollars to create five
million jobs
in manufacturing and tech innovation
i'll say that again
five million jobs in manufacturing and
tech innovation if you're looking for a
job
this might not be a bad career to look
into he wants to also create a hundred
thousand new jobs
in the public health sector and then
here's the big one just in case you
haven't been paying attention
he wants to increase the federal minimum
wage
up to 15 an hour the current federal
minimum wage
is 7.25 so almost doubling it so what's
the purpose that he would like to boost
the income
of 30 million low wage workers
now listen i haven't been given my
opinions too much about any of this
stuff i've been going straight down the
line
but here's why i will interject i will
tell you i am not exactly a huge fan
of increasing the minimum wage on a
federal level across the united states
i actually agree in certain expensive
cities
exp certain you know high cost states
new york california florida for example
just passed the 15
minimum wage i'm cool with that but you
don't need to be making 15
an hour in bumblefu oklahoma so that's a
little point of controversy would love
to get your perspective
on that point right there so that's the
minimum wage argument
moving right along this is probably the
biggest thing on the board
but we had to do it in alphabetical
order so let's address the stimulus this
is the big question
on everyone's mind what will happen with
another round of stimulus just to recap
it
where we last left off the democrats are
proposing a
two trillion dollar or more stimulus
package
while the republicans are saying homie
let's keep it below a trillion dollars
my guess is they'll somehow meet in the
middle
at 1.5 trillion dollars that's my
assumption we'll see if that happens
we all know what's been happening over
the last six months since they passed
the first stimulus pass there's been
ongoing negotiations
left right left right up down has just
been at a complete
impasse but when this does happen what
will the second round of stimulus
center around well we know that there'll
be likely more stimulus checks
more federal unemployment boosts they
will likely extend the ppp that's the
paycheck
protection program and last but not
least they will provide aid
to cities and states so that's what's on
the radar when it comes
to stimulus moving right along let's
talk about number eight
taxes taxes taxes this is maybe the
biggest part on here
that's debatable what is joe biden's
intentions when it comes to taxes
well it's pretty obvious he's going
after high earners and he would like
to reverse the trump 2017 corporate
tax cuts let's get into the numbers
right now now when it comes to raising
taxes here's the number that you need to
keep in mind the number is
hundred thousand dollars if you make
more than four hundred thousand dollars
your taxes will likely go up if you make
less
than four hundred thousand dollars your
taxes will likely
stay the same what else is on the agenda
well he would like to increase
the top rate from 37 percent to 39
so if you're making more than a half a
million dollars six hundred thousand
dollars
whether you're single or you're married
you're in the top top top one percent
top
tax bracket then you'll likely go up
from 37 to 39.6 percent
now what else does he like to do he
would like to increase the corporate tax
rate up from 21
to 28. i know if you're a corporation
you are not
happy about this if you own a
corporation would love to get your
thoughts on this
maybe just maybe if republicans fight
this we'll see what happens in congress
maybe they meet in the middle and they
call it 24 we shall
see this won't happen easily in congress
last but not least
he would like to increase the capital
gains from 23.8
up to 39.6 if if you make more than a
million dollars in income
let me just tell you if you're making
more than a million dollars in income
and you're watching this channel
respect to you brother or sister
side note you know for a fact just like
i have right here the gop
will fight this like crazy we talked at
the beginning of this that republicans
will more than likely control the senate
again it's an assumption but if they do
do not expect
taxes to change too much we
shall see how that plays out moving
right along let's talk about tech aka
big tech when we're talking about big
tech we're talking about facebook
we're talking about apple we're talking
about google we're talking about twitter
and what are they talking about with
that they certainly have been under
scrutiny
over the last few years facebook google
twitter as we discussed
both sides of the aisle on congress are
not exactly happy with big tech
and they are definitely not cool with
their unchecked
powers let's get into what biden is
thinking biden supports revoking
section 230 of the communications
decency
act which basically shields social media
companies
from content its users posts so
basically what does that mean
right now social media companies are
sort of exempt if someone on their
platform says something ridiculous or
outlandish or racist
they're like look i didn't say that what
biden is looking to do is maybe they say
buddy you're responsible for this that
might be a slippery slippery slope we'll
see how that plays out
obviously the big elephant in the room
when it comes to social media is
facebook facebook also owns instagram
the democrats and joe biden feel that
facebook does not do enough
to police disinformation whereas you
have on the republican side of things
on the right they believe that they're
censoring their content so that's what's
going on with this section 230 of this
communications decency
act last but not least biden says
breaking up big
tech would be a last resort option
we'll see what happens with that
rounding
the curve so to speak let's end up at
number 10 which is
trade this has obviously been a hot
button issue under the trump
administration
trump went hard on trade what did he go
hard on he went hard on allies
he went hard on international
organizations he went hard on border
taxes and imports
and he went even harder on china now
what does biden have to say
when it comes to trade well joe biden
has not indicated that he will reverse
what trump
has put in place when it comes to
tariffs on 360 billion dollars
worth of chinese goods let me say that
again biden might not change what trump
has done
when it comes to tariffs on chinese
goods what he is looking to do is reset
america's role as an ally and leader on
the world stage and what would he like
to do when it comes to china
well his intentions are aggressive
action on china
but and here's the but he would like his
allies to team up
to confront them not doing it alone that
is known as multi-lateralism
so that's your top 10 when it comes to
things you need to look out
when it comes to a joe biden economic
plan
now here are actually my biggest
takeaways from what we just uncovered
it's pretty clear
that number one joe biden is focusing on
low
and middle income households that have
been the hardest hit during the pandemic
a lot of his policies are here to help
average americans
get by that's pretty obvious if you look
at any of his proposals
also this is the most ambitious climate
change proposal
we have ever seen that's number two
number three
joe biden is actually not going too far
left i know he has
ran on being a moderate democrat but you
can see in any of his proposals right
here
he's definitely not in favor of
universal health care he's definitely
not in favor of the
new green deal so you have people like
bernie elizabeth warren and aoc saying
whose team are you on bro joe biden's
basically trying to say i'm in
the center what do you think about that
is he actually in the center
i'd love to hear your comments on that
what else if you're looking for jobs if
you're looking for jobs over the next
four
five ten years according to joe biden's
plan
the biggest jobs will be in
manufacturing tech
innovation green jobs obviously and
engineering
when it comes to infrastructure last but
not least
joe biden is not exactly doing any
favors for the top one percent
or for corporate america would love to
get your thoughts on that as well
here's my take when it comes to a joe
biden presidency what can you
do with this new president coming into
office well really
what you can do is you can control what
you can control what do i mean by that
you have no control over the stock
market you have no control of whether
congress
passes any of these proposals whatsoever
but what you can control
is your wealth and how much effort you
put
on a daily basis so one thing i'll tell
you no matter who is in office you need
to focus
on your wallet when it comes to your
wallet what have we seen over the last
basically 12 years whether it was an
obama presidency or whether a trump
presidency the stock market has gone up
up
up so invest for the long term now here
here's a friendly reminder of the six
things that you should focus on no
matter who is the president as you know
if you've seen any of my episodes i call
this
the size six principles of wealth number
one is you gotta have a game plan for
your money you need to focus on income
and limit your expenses this is
otherwise known as a budget number two
you need to eliminate high interest debt
from your life whether that's credit
card debt
or car loans or high interest student
loan debt get that out of your life and
the worst thing that you can have
is payday loans and cash advances get
that debt out of your life
number three as we all know around here
you better stack cash and
save that money before you can invest in
the stock market you need to have an
emergency fund
saved up number four for principle of
wealth is invest and invest in the long
term
as we just discussed whether trump's in
office whether obama is in office
now that biden's going to be in the
office the stock market tends to go up
over time
so play the long game and save to invest
that money
number five is ensure and protect your
biggest
asset which is you make sure that you
have health insurance make sure that you
have life insurance
if you've got kids for sure and make
sure you look into disability insurance
that will protect you if in case you get
injured and last but not least
what's your purpose what are you doing
with your free
time what are you doing if you could own
your time all this stuff you can't
control
but you can control your health your
wealth and your happiness and make sure
you're doing you
and what you want to be doing so that's
it that's this episode on the joe
biden economic plan 10 things that you
need to understand when it comes
to his presidency i would love to know
what's the number one thing
on your mind what's the number one thing
on your agenda i would love to check
that out
in the comments section again if you
have not seen my episode where i break
down the six principles of wealth
and how you can win the money game check
that out in this episode right here
and if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics please do so
below
and as always save that
money all we talk is